de Sandra Torres se podría llegar a
esperar que para segunda vuelta no acoja
en su seno el apoyo del partido vamos el
apoyo del partido de Alejandro yamatei
que para estos comicios quedó en tercer
lugar a través de su candidato Manuel
Conde Y es que recordemos que fue el
propio yamatei quien cuando llegó a la
presidencia cumplió una de sus promesas
de campaña de llevar a la justicia
Sandra Torres por presuntos delitos
electorales Por lo cual Torres pasó
varios meses en prisión sin embargo para
varios analistas estas asperezas podrían
limarse dado que la figura de Torres
representa un prisma en el cual puedan
llegar a confluir varios partidos
tradicionales donde se puedan sentir
cómodos y seguros Como por ejemplo la
coalición que representó a la candidata
de extrema derecha azul y ríos la
coalición valor unionista aunque se diga
de Sandra Torres que es la que pone
presidentes en segunda vuelta dado el
peso que carga a cuestas de un fuerte
anti voto son muchos los sectores tanto
conservadores como de pastores
evangélicos quienes la apoyan por su
parte Bernardo Arévalo tendría a su
favor el apoyo de todo el electorado
indígena que se sabe izquierda
progresista que sueña tener en el poder
a un presidente que no uso fluctúe de
los recursos públicos y valga notar que
Guatemala es un país donde cerca del 50%
de la población es indígena y también
recibiría el apoyo del electorado del
voto nulo todas esos esas personas
guatemaltecas que representan el hastío
de una política instrumentalizada para
favorecer a las élites de este país cómo
reaccionaron los jueces los periodistas
y los demás exiliados tras el paso de
Arévalo al balotaje
una de las voces más reconocidas en
Guatemala es la de Telma Aldana la
otrora fiscal general en los tiempos de
la sisic que dijo en Twitter
está lloviendo en Washington DC y yo
estoy llorando por mi país recordemos
que Aldana fue candidata presidencial
por el movimiento semilla el mismo que
está llevando a Arévalo a segunda vuelta
pero en su momento tuvo que escapar del
país por amenazas de muerte por su lucha
anticorrupción una lucha que llevó de la
mano con el ex comisionado Iván
Velázquez el ex comisionado de lasicic
actual ministro de defensa de Colombia
quien también en Twitter felicitó a
Guatemala diciendo a través de un poema
Podrán cortar todas las flores pero
siempre volverá la primavera florecerás
Guatemala un poema de Julia Esquivel por
su parte Juan Francisco Sandoval ex
fiscal anticorrupción quien escapó del
país luego de abrir una investigación de
presunta corrupción que salpicaba la
actual presidente Alejandro yamatei dijo
en Twitter por primera vez en muchos
días mi desvelo y Lágrimas son de
esperanza y los periodistas exiliados
recordaron que en esta jornada los
grandes perdedores fueron el ex
presidente Jimmy Morales el actual
presidente Alejandro yamatei y quien se
considera su escudera la fiscal general
Consuelo porras